في كثير من الأحياء ، تكون الحديقة العامة
هي مركز المجتمع
، وملعب كرة السلة هو مركز
تلك الحديقة العامة في كثير من الأحيان في هذه
الملاعب التي تكون في شكل خشن
، حيث توجد ملاعب إما لا توجد بها
خطوط أو توجد بها فجوات وشقوق كبيرة
في  على سطح الملعب ، يمكن أن يكون هناك
انخفاضات كبيرة قد تكون غير آمنة وخطيرة
للعب ، لذا فإن رؤية كل هذه الملاعب في
جميع أنحاء المدينة ألهمني لتجديد
ملاعب كرة السلة العامة في الهواء الطلق
والتعاون مع الفنانين لإنشاء
أعمال فنية فريدة للسطح الذي
لعبت به كثيرًا  في هذه المحكمة ،
كانت حياتي كلها لا تحتاج إلى تفكير بالنسبة لي مثلما
انتهزت الفرصة لأكون قادرًا
على النزول والمساعدة في الرسم ورد
الجميل للمجتمع
[الموسيقى]
لينكين بارك هي محكمة خاصة بالنسبة لي
لأنني اعتدت على  ألعب هنا
عندما كنت في المدرسة ، نشأ جميع أشقائي وهم
يلعبون في هذا الملعب ، وبالتالي فإن
هذه المحاكم قد مرت وقتًا طويلاً ، حيث تستغرق
العملية الفعلية لتجديد الملعب
عادةً حوالي أسبوعين
عادةً ما سأعين طاقمًا متعاقدًا محليًا
للقيام بأي إصلاح للكسر أو
الإصلاح ، وبعد الانتهاء من ذلك ،
نأتي بمجرد ظهور المحكمة
لإنهاء العمل الفني
والاستعداد لتناول طعام الغداء منذ بدء
اللوحة الخلفية للمشروع  قبل ثلاث سنوات ونصف ،
عملنا في أكثر من عشرين
ملعبًا حول العالم ، كان أحد أكثر
الأجزاء متعةً هو العمل مع
متطوعين من المجتمع في لوحة المحكمة التي
ستبدأ عند خط الشريط وسنعمل على
طريقتنا  إلى الوراء ، أنت تعرف
أن ملعب كرة السلة بالنسبة لي كان
دائمًا مكانًا تعلمت فيه أن تكون
مواطنًا مشاركًا حتى تقابل
جيرانك وتجتمع معًا
لغرض مشترك ، وأعتقد كثيرًا
أن الناس يفكرون في ملاعب كرة السلة على أنها
مصدر إزعاج عندما  إنه مكان
يمكنه حقًا أن يجمع الأشخاص والمجتمعات
معًا قبل ذلك ، فقد كانت تصدعات في جميع
أنحاء المحكمة ، وكانت الكتابة على الجدران في كل مكان
بالتأكيد شكلاً سيئًا يعيد
إلى المجتمع نوعًا ما يتحدث إلي
لأنه  أشارك نوعًا ما
في مشروع كهذا وهو
بالتأكيد مصدر إلهام للأطفال الآخرين
نظرًا لحقيقة أنك تعرف أن جيل الشباب
دائمًا ما يتطلع إلى الجيل الأكبر
سنًا الذي يرون أنك تقدمه
لهم ، ألهمهم لرد الجميل
[الموسيقى]
إذا كان بإمكانهم التقدم  واحد معطف جديد
تم تجديده ، إنه مخدر جدًا ، لا
يبدو صغيراً فقط ملعب كرة سلة ،
لكنك تعلم أنه أكثر بكثير من مجرد خروج الجميع من العمل ، حيث
يأتي الأشخاص
الذين لا يعيشون في نيو روشيل
إلى هنا لمشاهدة المباراة  لذلك
بالتأكيد تساعد الأشياء الصغيرة في
ذلك ، لم يبدأ هذا كثيرًا لأن
مشروعًا فنيًا لم يبدأ كطريقة
لجلب الفن إلى المتنزهات ، لكنني أعتقد أنني
أدرك أنه من المهم حقًا بالنسبة
لي إلهام ومساعدة الآخرين على القيام بذلك  في
مجتمعاتهم الخاصة ، كما تعلم ، أريد
أن يشعر الناس أنني أستطيع إحداث
فرق في مجتمعي ، ربما لا
أرسم ملعب كرة سلة بأكمله ، ربما
أشتري شبكات جديدة
وأعلقهم عندما يسقطون ، ربما أنا فقط
التقاط ال  قمامة ، فأنت تعرف أيًا
كان الأمر إذا كنت تهتم بحديقتك ،
فأنت تهتم بملعب كرة السلة الذي تقيم
فيه
[موسيقى]